[Music]
you moved in you moved into a new house
yeah and I'm told that you that you have
an interesting decoration in your house
yes I do and I don't know what to do
with it which is why I show I'm gonna
show it to you and maybe you can help me
because this artist David Cho this
Korean artist who I think he was a thief
and he was in jail for you yeah you're
one to talk
he's a thief he's like a real he's like
I don't know what he stole but he was in
jail and then when he got out he painted
a naked picture of me he painted a naked
picture of you now
he painted a picture of a naked woman
and then he said it he says it's me
right and that he gave he gave her Asian
eyes and then his feet and then ah the
perfect woman wait so let me backtrack
he wrote me a letter okay we don't need
to know the whole thing Lily he made his
painting for you he somehow got in touch
with me because he's a fan of our show
and he he asked if he could bring over a
housewarming gift for me I've never met
him before in my life
he showed up to my house in a white suit
with no shoes on barefoot and gave me a
painting on a piece of wood that's
bigger than me that is just a naked me
and then just gave it to me and then he
went outside and jumped in my pool and
then he left and anyway I feel like a
policeman taking a report I think I
should be writing this down so and and
then the painting you say is a little
it's a little you'll see it I want to
show you let's look at this paints on
your dining room right now
so then Thanksgiving came around and I
have my family over and I put it there
and I made my mom sit like right where
she could see it yeah I'm sure hard to
miss that Wow I congratulations on that
painting